Gooood morning Hank, it's Sunday. Special
bonus video!
So as you know, for the past couple of years
Nerdfighteria has been sponsoring AFC Wimbledon,
an actual professional soccer team in England.
They play in League 2, so called because it
is the fourth tier of English soccer, and
they're just an amazing club: they're owned
by their fans, they were the first football
club in England to take a stand against homophobia,
and they worked their way up all the way from
the bottom of the amateur ranks, the ninth
tier of football, to being a full-time professional
team. It's an amazing story. By the way, we
pay for the sponsorship by sending AFC Wimbledon
all the advertising revenue from our channel
hankgames, so called because only John plays
games on it.
Anyway, Hank, this year we were able to increase
the size of our sponsorship so we could actually
get on their pants. We are on the shorts of
the actual AFC Wimbledon uniform! There's
even these awesome AFC Wimbledon scarves that
have DFTBA on them -- by the way, these are
back in stock at dftba.com, all the royalties
go to the club -- and perhaps because they
are constantly being reminded by their shorts
not to forget to be awesome, AFC Wimbledon
have had a great season this year, Hank.
They're twelfth in their league, which sounds
bad, but for a club that's owned not by a
rich person but by a bunch of regular people,
it's excellent. And, in the big nationwide
competition known as the F.A. Cup, they have,
for the first time, made it to round three,
the round when, like, all the big teams enter
the competition.
So that means that AFC Wimbledon could have
been drawn against Manchester United or Arsenal
or Chelsea; they could have made more from
one of those games than they make in twenty
years of nerdfighter sponsorships. Now, then
again, they also could have been drawn against,
like, Yeovil Town, so I was very nervous on
the Paper Towns set when I was watching the
draw come in.
And then, in the middle of a take of the movie,
I shouted, "Are you FRENCH THE LLAMA kidding
me?!", and thereby ruined the take of the
movie, because AFC Wimbledon had been drawn
against... Liverpool football club, the team
that I have supported for my entire adult
life.
Hank, I know this sounds weird to people who
don't care about sports, but Liverpool really
has helped me through some of the hardest
times in my life. Hank, as you know, Liverpool
is an embarrassingly large part of my life.
I mean, Hank, the day both my children came
home from the hospital, I showed them Liverpool's
Champions League Final victory over AC Milan
because I wanted it to be the first thing
they ever saw on a screen.
So the football club I love most in the world
versus the football club that literally has
DFTBA on their shorts. What's a guy to do?
Well, Hank, in my case, fly with the Yeti
to London for the game -- in fact, we live
in about two hours.
By the way, Hank, the game is on American
television at 3 P.M. Eastern on the cable
network Fox Sports One. So you can watch the
game and, like, see the nerdfighter advertisements
by the side of the field.
If you're a nerdfighter who doesn't care about
sports, and your parents just don't understand,
this is a great opportunity to connect. They'll
be like, "What is this strange cult that you're
a part of that sponsors fourth-tier English
soccer teams?" and you'll be like, "Ah, that's
not even weird. They're also trying to genetically
engineer puppy-sized elephants."
As for who I'm going to support, Hank, in
the end I -- I looked way down deep into the
darkness inside of me at my very core and
what I saw there was a guy who really does
intensely and irrationally care about the
community that is Liverpool football club,
but ultimately a guy who just has to root
for the team with DFTBA on their shorts.
Like, in some ways, the question is, "What
do you care about more, Liverpool or Nerdfighteria,
as symbolized in this case by AFC Wimbledon,
and then there's no contest! Obviously, Nerdfighteria!"
Augh, but even so, Hank, I do not recommend
divided loyalties. It's extremely stressful.
Now, of course, some of you argue that who
I choose to support matters nothing to the
actual game, and to you I say, " Well yes,
but the sport also doesn't matter; it's just
a bunch of people trying to kick a ball into
a net." We make it meaningful by caring about
it. That doesn't just go for sports; it goes
for lots of stuff.
OK, Hank, I have to go get on an airplane
now so I can spend 14 hours in England. And
lastly, I just want to say a special thank
you to everyone who watches the AFC Wimbledon
Wimbly Womblys on hankgames, because you made
this possible. As it says on AFC Wimbledon's
shorts, don't forget to be awesome.